STEVE: THE BIDEN REGIME ON THE
BORDER CRISIS THEY CREATED AND
WITH THE TUCSON ARIZONA CHIEF
OF POLICE WAS NAMED THE HEAD
OF NEW CBP DO THINK THINGS ARE
BAD NOW WAIT UNTIL THIS GUY IS
IN  CHARGE.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE WE HAVE A
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER?
YES OR NO.
>> DOES IT REALLY MATTER IF WE
CALL IT A MAJOR CHALLENGE OR
CRISIS?
AND A BIG PROBLEM QUICK.
>> IT'S NOT A CRISIS AT THE
BORDER.
>> NO.
I DON'T THINK.
STEVE: NO CRISIS IT GOES
COMPLETELY ACCORDING TO PLAN
AND IN A SICK WAY THAT IS TRUE
BEFORE THE ELECTION BIDEN
CALLED FOR A SURGE OF THE
BORDER AND WHAT ARE THEY DOING
WITH THOSE PEOPLE?
THEY ARE FLYING AROUND THE
COUNTRY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT OUT OF SIGHT OF THE
MEDIA THE NEW YORK POST CAUGHT
THEM IN THE ACT WE KNOW FROM
BORDER PATROL DOCUMENTS AT
LEAST 150,000 HAS BEEN
RELEASED INTO THE US WITH
LITTLE OR NEWS SUPERVISION
SINCE MARCH.
WE NOW HAVE A TOTAL OF
ONE.7 MILLION ENCOUNTERS JUST
THIS YEAR IN HERE WITH
REACTION FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
I SAW YOU TALKING ABOUT THIS
THE OTHER NIGHT.
AND YOU HAD SOME SHOCKING DATA
NUMBERS ON THE SCALE OF THE
PROBLEM THAT YOU MANAGED TO
GET A HOLD OF SO CAN YOU TELL
US ABOUT THAT AGAIN AND YOUR
REACTION TO WHAT WE LEARNED
THIS WEEK?
>> THAT WAS THE NUMBER OF
RELEASES IN TWO SECTORS FROM
MARCH TO THE PRESENT THE
BORDER PATROL RELEASES ARE
600,000 THAT'S ON THE WEBSITE
TITLE EIGHT AND TITLE 18
ACTIONS 600,009 NUMBER ONE IS
ANOTHER LIFE YOU LOOK AT
BORDER PATROL IT IS ONE.NINE
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT COUNTING
THE ALIENS AT SHOP IMPORTANT
ENTRY SO YOU ADD TO THAT THE
400,000 OTHERS YOU HAVE
TWO.3 MILLION THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN LYING
FROM THE BEGINNING AND THEY
CONTINUE TO LIVE AT THEY SAY
THAT BORDER IS SECURE WITH
TWO.3 MILLION IS RIDICULOUS
AND IN DELL RIO THEY SAY DON'T
COME YOU WILL NOT SUCCEED YOU
WILL BE DEPORTED AND THEN
MEANWHILE 15000 WALK OUT THE
BACK DOOR.
SO THIS ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES LINE THEY ARE NON-
APOLOGETIC BECAUSE THEY LIE TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THEY WANT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE DOING AND IN THE
CITIES THAT ARE NOT EXPECTING
THEM I HAVE NEVER SEEN AN
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT ON -┘-
OUTRIGHT LIE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
>> IT'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
STEVE: THE NUMBERS ARE SO
STAGGERING YOU HAVE
TO.3 MILLION TOTAL NUMBER.
IS THAT THE NUMBER WHO IS
SHOWING UP AT THE BORDER AND
600,000 COMING IN OUR WHAT ARE
THE TOTAL?
BREAK ON -┘- BREAK DOWN THOSE
NUMBERS AGAIN.
STEVE: ONE.SEVEN BORDER PATROL
ENCOUNTERS ONE.NINE WET AT THE
BORDER.
STEVE: YOU MEAN PEOPLE DOING
IT THE RIGHT WAY?
>> NO NO NO.
THE PORT OF ENTRY IS THE RIGHT
WAY TO CLEAN SILENT THAT IS
FALSE CLAIMS.
STEVE.
>> NOW YOU AND THE FOUR.SEVEN
GOD A WAY THAT IS FROM THE
NUMBERS FROM THE FED MENU AND
ONE.NINE AND TWO.3,600,000
RELEASES INTO THE COUNTRY IF
YOU ADD TO THAT THE 400,000
GOT AWAY THAT IS 1 MILLION
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THE COUNTRY
THAT WILL NEVER LEAVE AND THEY
ARE HERE TO STAY.
STEVE: SO TO MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND THE TERM GOT AWAY
THAT IS WHAT AN AGENT MIGHT
SEE TO TRY TO APPREHEND BUT
THEY GOT AWAY QUICK.
>> THESE MEAN THEY ARE NOT
ARRESTED IS BASED ON TRAFFIC
AND DRAWN TRAFFIC THE BORDER
PATROL DID NOT RESPOND TO
BECAUSE 15 PERCENT ARE IN
THESE FACILITIES ALSO WANT TO
MENTION CLAIMING 192,000 AND
INTENT ARE ON -┘- ENCOUNTERS BY
BORDER PATROL NO.
THAT IS THE NUMBER ARRESTED BY
BORDER PATROL THAT IF YOU TAKE
50 PERCENT OFF THAT MEANS THE
ENCOUNTERS FOUND MORE GOT
AWAY.
SO THEN TO BE IN DEL RIO WITH
15000 MIGRANTS AND THEN
224 MILES OF BORDER.
SO THEY HAD LESS ENCOUNTERS.
BUT THE NUMBER OF GOT A WAYS
CONTINUES THE CLAIM.
BUT THEY CREATED THAT BECAUSE
OF THE OPEN BORDER BY THE
ECOLOGY.
THINK I'D YOU ARE ON THIS.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT YOU ARE
KEEPING AN EYE ON IT TO GET
THE INFORMATI